all right if you watch the show on
Friday or you follow me on to my Twitter
feed you probably saw how we took on
Jimmy Kimmel with examples of his past
antics after he frankly was kind of
bullying the first lady in my opinion
who clearly is not in any position to
defend herself by making fun of her
accent well she's actually reading to
children now after we did call Kimmel
out he responded with even more vicious
attacks anyway yesterday Kimmel
apologized for some of his behavior he
wrote in part by lampooning Sean
Hannity's deference to the president I
most certainly did not intend to
belittle or upset members of the gay
community and to those who took offense
I apologize I will take Sean Hannity at
his word that he was genuinely offended
by what I believed and still believed to
be a harmless and silly aside
referencing of our first lady's accent
mrs. Trump almost certainly has enough
to worry about without being used as a
prop to increase TV ratings all right
I read the apology carefully a couple of
things are pretty clear to me on the
surface I'll be honest it seems to be
more of a kind of a forced Disney
corporate apology directed more towards
the LGBTQ community rather than about
Kimmel's comments about the first lady
but honestly that's ultimately up to you
to decide here I believe everyone should
accept apologies that's how I was raised
that's what my religion teaches me and
I'm gonna assume he's sincere but from
my perspective I really do kind of enjoy
a good fight and I do agree with Jimmy
in the sense it's time to move on now
for me what this was really about it's
never about hannity versus Jimmy Kimmel
it's a lot bigger than that for me and
here's why just the level of hatred
vitriol against this president and his
family is frankly unprecedented as we've
been talking about all night tonight the
left in this country they've even
attacked the president's what 10 11 12
year old son and what's even worse is we
have this corrupt media industrial
complex we see it all working tonight
daily breathlessly saying pretty much
anything and everything in an effort to
literally hurt this president and bring
his family down now attacking the first
lady for her accent while reading to
kids is just one small example but it's
a line in the sand for me it's obvious
that Melania Barron they're not
political in their role
and those cheap shots I'm saying need to
end look I was a tough critic
people have been riding under your tough
critic of President Obama and his
policies and you always talked about him
and Michelle and going to the Church of
Gd America and hanging out with Bill
Ayers and Bernardine Dohrn and Reverend
Wright and so on and so forth and that's
all true by the way
and I also criticized Michelle Obama's
political statements like I couldn't
believe a couple of times she said for
the first time in my adult life I'm
proud of my country I'm like really
makes no sense and the liberal media is
trying to say that my commentary of
Michelle Obama's political statements is
somehow similar to what Jimmy Kimmel
said about Melania Trump frankly that's
a lie they know it I was criticizing
Michelle Obama on the substance of her
political comments by the way no one
will ever report that I have said
multiple times on radio and TV Michelle
and Barack Obama seemed like they were
wonderful parents that their kids seemed
wonderful and they raise good kids and
they did a good job because it's not
easy being in the public eye and that
kid should be left alone I said it many
times that's the difference and I think
that's a big one and unlike the Obamas
President Trump and the first lady it
seems that they're not given any
courtesy by anybody at this point which
proves my larger point the media is now
wholly an extension of the Democratic
Party this show and a few other voices
on this network and talk radio we're the
rare exceptions to this rule look on
your screen the eight years of Obama's
policies failed you the American people
on a spectacular level nobody in the
media reported this and I think that's
what the last election was about The
Forgotten men and women of this country
and poverty on food stamps and out of
the labor force liberal media never
talked about it we have an endless
stream of lies propaganda conspiracy
theories cheap shot personal attacks my
point in all of this is at the end of
the day it's hurting those American
people and it's really hurting the
ability of the president even having a
month to do his job but for me this is
the line in the sand you leave women and
kids alone I'm done and that's why I
took on Jimmy Kimmel I'm not trying to
be the thought police and I sure don't
want political correctness I've never
supported boycotts never will and Jimmy
by the way conservatives like me to
support illegal immigration we're not
anti immigration we believe in legal
immigration and just as responsible
people can disagree
about some of the crazy things you've
done in the past I say let the audience
decide and I've noticed by the way Jimmy
you seem focused on politics he seems
sincere when you talked about health
care you seem sincere when you talk
about the country I want to extend an
invitation you want to come on this show
I'll promise no name-calling no anger no
rehashing of the Twitter fight you want
to have a serious discussion we can talk
about the president is policies health
care comedy political correctness any
more cots how I've supported Bill Maher
Howard Stern Don Imus Opie and Anthony
people that I think disagree with
vehemently my bet is you'll actually
agree with me on a lot more issues than
you think but from my point of view it's
over let Jimmy Kimmel but I meant what I
said
unfair attacks there need to be an end
to this there's no shortage by the way
of comedic material out there by the way
Jimmy if you do want to start up again I
promise I'll punch back even harder and
my producers spent all weekend compiling
a lot of your highlights or lowlights in
your career they don't make you look too
good so instead of error airing them
we'll put them in storage and we have
more important pressing issues like
what's happening in Syria and the
gassing of women and children